今日入ってきたこのデニムは尾道デニムです
2013年1月日本人のものづくりに込める精神性と尾道の街の魅力を日本全国にせ足
そして世界に発信しようという目的で尾道デニムプロジェクトは始まりました
ここで用いたメディアは世界でも多くの方々に愛されている
このデニムです
この道を含むりんご地方は日本有数のデニムの産地であり
世界的なブランドも手掛けるほどのクオリティを誇っています
しかし時代の移り変わりの中で海外へ生産がシフト c
繊維業全体が衰退の1等をたどっています
またこの尾道は
観光地なんて名前は知られていますが
新しい文化や旅人を受け入れる人々の懐の深さという本来の魅力の発信が課題の1つで
もあります
このプロジェクトに必要なものはまずこのデニムです
りんご長の職人技が詰まったブランドリゾルトです
デニムデザイナーの林克征市は長年磯野でにも追い続けてきた形であり
頑ななこだわりで職人たちを牽引してきた人物でもあります
そしてこのデニムは履き込む事で体になじんでいく造りが大きな特徴です
このデニムを尾道働く方々に1人に2本お渡しし新品の状態でお渡しします
それをワークパンツとして1年間入ってもらいます
職業は第9集職漁師
農家保育士などさまざま世代は大学生から70代までと3世代にわたります
仕事や日々の暮らしのなかで刻まれる手話や自然ない同地をすべて個性としこのデニム
の価値とします
機械加工では決して作り出すことのできない世界に1本だけのヴィンテージでにも作り
それは尾道デニムとして発進販売をしようという試みです
このデニムを履き込む事で答え差が出ることが大きな特性でありその特性を生かすため
実際にプロジェクトの参加者を集めがスタートしました
条件は3つ
尾道を愛する人
個性的な人そして最低でも週4日でにも履いて働けることです
目標人数は200名
当初右も左もわからない街へ取り組むプロジェクト
もちろん知り合いもいません
そんな中
街の取り組みの中心人物を紹介していただく機会に恵まれ
直接このプロジェクトの趣旨をプレゼンすることとなります
中には自分たちが入ったデニムに価値があるのか
て2問者ことがどのように町おこしにつながるのかなどと
いろんな疑問を投げかけられることもありましたが
結果として
面白いからとりあえずやってみようという声から始まり
270名の方たちとスタートすることができました
このように
前例のないことでも面白がって取り組む尾道の方たちがいるからこそ
そして人のつながりを大切にする尾道の人たちだからこそ
このプロジェクトは今でも熱を持って継続できています
しかし
これらの価値を伝えていくためにもただ履きこんだでにも作ればいいというわけでは
ありません
ヴィンテージデニムとしてのクオリティー母にも大切にしました
6にこの映像にある洗い方について
参加者の方々にお渡したデニムは基本的に好きに履きこんでもらっていいのですが家庭
での洗濯は極力避け
デザイナーが信頼する島根県の荒井の専門工場にお送りします
そのために毎週木曜日の配布回収は欠かせません
参加者の仕事現場に直接回収しに行ったり
背景るでにも私たちの方に持ってきて頂いたりとコミュニケーションを取りながら毎週
毎週配布回収を行いました
そして回収車デニムは島根県の工場に送り
職人さんたちが目を通して丁寧に洗いにかけます
この吐く洗うという工程を毎週
経年変化を確認しながら1年間繰り返します
この一見手間がかかる作業を欠かさないことがそれこそが日本人のものづくりの精神性
でありこのデニムに刻まれた個性がより磨かれる秘密です
講師出来上がったデニムには
参加者の職業やライフスタイルの違いが刻まれています
例えばこちらのデニム
これは尾道で働く漁師さんも履いたものです
よく見るとここに白い線が入ってますこれは長靴を履いて所働く時に出来た芝です
奥のデニム少しこの辺が黒くなっています
あとここの辺りに少し白い穴が開いています
この職業は抵抗所で働く職人さんです
溶接の時に飛び散る火花や鉄粉がこのデニムに刻まれています
このようにたくさんの個性が刻まれたデニムは胃瘻地や状態に合わせた値段の付け方に
なっていますが
実は吐き気の個性そんなものがこのデニムの大きな価値となっているのです
そして2014年3月尾道商店街に尾道デニムショップが応答しました
インターネットなどが半田岩瀬販売はせず基本的にはこのお店での対面販売になります
そうすることで遠方からわざわざ尾道デニムとの出会いを楽しみに足を運んでくださる
流れが生まれてきました
ちなみに第一号の購入者は地元の高校生
バイトで稼いだお金は手切りしべてでにも買いに来てくれた姿を今でも強く思い出す
ことができます
私がこのプロジェクトを企画した原動力
それはタイやインドでの経験を通じて感じた心が震えるようなもの心から感動すること
を大切な方に伝えたいという思いからです
20代のころものがないならない内の生活を経験してみようとタイ北部に胃痛店内に
行きそこで1年間生活をしました
そのシンプルな暮らしから
生きていくために働くという大切なことを学びました
そしてこの画像はインドの子ジャイサルメールと言います
ジャイサルメールは黄金の町と呼ばれています
この街に夕日が落ちる瞬間街一帯が黄金色に輝く風景を目にし
とてつもなく感動をしこの感動を大切な人たちに伝えたいとホテルの立ち上げに携わる
ことになります
帰国後はここでのこれらの経験をどうにか別の形で生かせないかそう考えたのです
そんな中東日本大震災があり
被害のあった福島県南相馬市の現状を知り
何かできないかと考えました
大切なのは表九を風化させないこと日常が当たり前ではないということ
そして皆が繋がっているということそれらの気づきを促すような写真店を運営しました
その手法は震災から半年そして1年の日の空の写真を sns でや口コミで世界中
日本中から数千枚集めそれらは一枚の写真につなぎ
思いとともに被災地へ寄贈するというものです
もちろん我々の想いとともに皆さんの集めた思いとともに起動しました
この参加型の作品作りという手法からこの尾道デニムプロジェクトはヒントを得てい
ます
そして自然な流れでいただいたこの尾道の仕事
瀬戸内の観光をし現に地域に事業と雇用を創出するという会社の理念に共感をもしまた
訪れた尾道の街や人に大変感動をしこの街で働くことを決意しました
この尾道の街は
昔も今もこれからも変わらない普遍的な価値が脈々と受け継がれている街です
このマジを舞台に今何が本当に大切かの本質を探り
価値あることを日本全国そして世界へと瀬谷していけるのです
働くこと生きることの価値を問い直したい
そして今はいける自分たちが本当に必要なものが何かを大切かを考え続けたい
それを試行錯誤しながら表現しようとしているのがこのデニムプロジェクトなのです
そんな1年目の上の中で見えてきた課題を改善するためにプロジェクトは
フェイズ2へ移行します
phase マンではプロジェクトの立ち上げとショップのオープン
そしてフェイズ2では尾道デニムを尾道から日本全国そして世界へと広げていこうと
いう試みに挑戦しました
このプロジェクトの広がりにクリエイティブの存在は欠かせません
デザインや sns の活用する一方で
あくまでも人から人へとこのデニムの価値を伝えていきたいと考えました
その手法の一つにこの尾道デニムスターターキット
新品のデニムとこのキットを購入していただくとデニムの内側に
ロットナンバーのスタンプが押され尾道で今の最大の特徴であるハクハイターとの新井
風合いを出す新井を専門の工場で体験することができます
自分の手にも一から育てるという楽しみを体験できるヒットです
そして2つめに尾道デニムキャラバン
を飲み地でに尾道になかなか足を運べない方のために
尾道デニムを尾道以外の土地に持ち込み
対面で魅力をお伝えするそんな試みです
訪れた土地で新たな人とのつながりを作り
またそこで発見した魅力も尾道デニムというメディアを通して発信することでメディア
としてのあり方を深めています
ここで大切なのは売り上げだけではなく
きちんと皆様に価値をお伝えすることです
尾道デニムが伝えていきたいことをまだまだいろんな人たちに伝えるために
テレビや雑誌新聞などのメディアの拡散に頼るだけではなくあくまでも人から人へと
つなげていきたいとそう考えています
そんな中で生まれた企画がこのたびするデニム
国内外問わず尾道デニムの遺志を受け継いでくれる方に尾道でにも実際にお渡しし
破棄さでてもらいます
新たな発生とともに履き込む事でそのデニムには新しい物語が刻まれます
同時に果ての皆様にはその土地の暮らし文化働き方など
デニムに刻まれるストーリーをシェアしてもらいます
現在では京都の職人さん萩野ゲストハウスオーナー
自転車をで世界一周中の旅人
そしてドイツに留学州の青年などさまざまな形に発動でてもらいます
これので人もいつか旅先から尾道に戻ってきていっ
また販売され別の方の手に渡る予定です
をの店にもはく全ての方々が物語の主人公です
何百人の手に尾道デニムが渡りいつか尾道に戻ってくる事その時のデニムの深みを増し
た表情
剥製の物語を聴ける日が来ることを楽しみにしています
そしてこのプロジェクトは決して一人では成立しないプロジェクトです
頑ななこだわりで理想のでにも追い続けてきた
デザイナーと
備後繊維協会に危機を感じていたものとの出会い
そしてファッション業界に携わり続けるものだからこそ知る
価値あるモノづくりの大変さ
尾道デニムの価値を表現してくれたグラフィックデザイナー
テレビで尾道デニムのことを知り関東から飛んできた女の子は今ではソップの看板娘
です
そして何より前例のないことでも面白がっており受け入れてくれた
尾道の方々は味のあるでにもそうてる職人なのです
このように尾道デニムを通して街と人との出会いがつながり
働くことに誇りを持つきっかけとなり誰かの人生と尾道の街とに新たな出会いが生まれ
ました
こうしてこのプロジェクトはシンプルな答えにたどり着くのです
一生懸命働くことはカッコいいということ
その街のフードは人々の日々のず営みの積み重ねが作り出す溺死であるということ
そして人にはそれぞれ個性や物語がありそこに価値を見いだすのは自分自身であると
いうことです
わたしたちはこの世界を生きる一人ひとりの人生が時代をつくるうえでとても大切な
一端を担っているということ
つながっていること
そして輝いているということをこのプロジェクトを通して表現し伝えていくことが
できるそう信じています